our next comedian uh was a famous sitcom
star ran into some trouble along the way
now he's back out doing
standup ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
Kramer all right good to be here
uh yeah going to be back here in New
York uh yeah going to be back in the
city you know going to be back here in
New York
[Music]
City always want to come to
Brooklyn hey guys seriously hey can I
can I do my ACT here jeez uh I'm just
trying to do my show I'm trying to do a
new standup tour
uh guys really could you T it
down all right what's your problem huh
what are you doing to me noit man look
just trying to do some jokes here yeah
you some jokes trying to do some jokes
trying something where's all right I
came prepared in case this what happened
hey
Tony will you [__] shut the [__]
up thank you
w